[Music]
good evening you're watching the World
News from sky television news on the
hour every hour what a day it had been
for mrs. Thatcher she finally conceded
that the game was up she could no longer
hold her job the war started at 12:50
local time 10:00 to 11:00 in Britain
hundreds of Allied bombers and fighters
headed for Iraq to drop during their
first raid some 18,000 tons of bombs no
sign of sadness from a woman who knew a
dramatic announcement was about to be
made about her failed marriage it is
announced from Buckingham Palace that
with regret The Prince and Princess of
Wales have decided to separate
closed-circuit TV cameras inside Bootle
strand shopping center offered the best
hope of finding tiny James pictures from
them show the child following two youths
then holding the hand of one of the
youngsters as he heads towards the exit
duly elected president of the Republic
of South Africa we the jury in the
above-entitled action find the defendant
Orenthal James Simpson not guilty of the
crime of murder in violation of Penal
Code section 187 a a felony upon Nicole
Brown Simpson groups of parents stunned
and disbelieving have gathered outside
the scene of the atrocity for many the
enormity of what has happened is still
to Sinkin II was just absolutely
horrified because it's a kind of
close-knit community don't blame the
precise details are still sketchy but
the Meseta 600 carrying the princess her
egyptian companion Dodi al-fayed a
driver and a bodyguard emerged from the
tunnel a complete crumpled wreck indeed
I did have a relationship with Miss
Lewinsky that was not appropriate in
fact it was wrong across the country
tens of millions of Americans listened
to their president pour out his heart
the final countdown and then loud
celebrations for twenty
in Brussels thought they hope will be a
happy new euro as the notes and coins
became legal the petrol prices may be
over but the queues are still long and
almost inevitably tempers are short the
Twin Towers of the World Trade Center
were the most potent symbol of America's
financial power now they have been
destroyed and with them the lives of
thousands of ordinary Americans but the
attacks were not limited just to the
streets of New York this will not be a
campaign of half-measures and we will
accept no outcome but victory the attack
came sooner than most analysts had
expected and was launched the Pentagon
says in response to credible
intelligence about the whereabouts of
members of the Iraqi leadership
including perhaps Saddam Hussein himself
[Music]
the sights and sounds of a tsunami
sweeping all before it this shaky video
shot by terrified tourists
it was a day long feared in the capital
a coordinated series of bomb attacks
above and below ground targeting
London's transport system with
predictably appalling consequences in
the shallow brackish waters of the tidal
Thames the stricken mammal was out of
its depth the 20-foot bottlenose whale
lost and disorientated in the currents
every parent will feel the anguish of
Jerry and Kate McCann as they await for
news of their daughter mrs. McCann
clutched a child's toy as her husband
read a prepared statement to the media
what cannot describe the anguish and
despair we are feeling he made history
every step of the way with the longest
the costliest the most grueling race in
election history but in the end only one
record matters Barack Obama will be the
first black president of America from
Hollywood to Harlem Seoul to Sydney the
death of the King of Pop has stunned
millions for who Michael Jackson
provided the soundtrack to their lives
this is the sky news leaders debate with
Adam Bolton rarely in political history
can three men have been tasked with
delivering so much in so little time
David Cameron Nick Clegg and Gordon
Brown after three nights of unbridled
lawlessness across London the contagion
is spreading morally to new areas of the
capital but now two regional cities to
cheers from the thousands watching on
the riverbank as the flotilla took shape
moving down the seven mile route under
14 Road foot and rail bridges this
historical inspiration became clear for
months the world had been waiting for
this moment
a protective father an adoring mother
together they showed off their son and
future king for the very first time
you've been watching the start up
transmissions from Sky News and Sky
television stay with us